he was a force last year Harper on the
drive great pass I'd admit it it has
been problematic for them bomber with
the three he didn't have a problem with
it no and here's the thing mark it's not
just the distance everybody thinks it's
the distance and it's leading by one
just in a way here as we approach the
midway point
Harper off the screen great in and out
move over Mitchell Robinson off glass
Andre to sit some nights and watch and
learn rather than have to be in a fire
all the time but if that's the case
they're going to be close to full at the
roster so some of these guys here
competing for the Sun believe it's about
those two way spots on the roster
the one thing forgiven ox to me is just
finding that consistency right this is
talents there the game comes easy lob up
iron with the left hand
Mitchell Robinson play under way quickly
here in the third quarter Mark Jones
puts that along with Doris Burke Cassidy
Hubbard as well and Palmer gets Phoenix
on the board first here in the second
half what's on Euroleague teens and
Spain Italy Lithuania grace oh my
goodness
spike that ducts of mr. Robinson look at
this get enough shots together you know
playing someone's liked I said so right
now it's all about exciting game going
on here right now what is it what do you
feel I know you're itching to play
Harper probing rice from deep boy will
grab and go for RJ and throws it away
Palmer good contest rest a kiss from
teeth pricked it may miss badly
and the sons with numbers if they wanted
Palmer with the crossover Prez Dacus mix
very much alive it'll need a three but
he'll take one anyway
roll so he gets mr. Robinson to change
the angle a little bit on the screen
polo to inbound jumper couple bounces
Robinson clears New York by a deuce rice
for the six on the clock that's got to
be at least the fourth built ending call
against Mitchell Robbins they call a
play form here at the end good fine to
Braz Dacus Robinson denied at the buzzer
and the sun's will win it 105